good evening thank you for joining us we
start with breaking news this hour and
the Hollywood star Alec Baldwin has been
charged with involuntary manslaughter
over the death of cinematographer Helena
Hutchins on the set of the film rust she
died after a prop gun held by Baldwin
was fired during rehearsals for the
movie in October of 2021.
well let's go live to Los Angeles and
our correspondent Martha Kellner hello
to you Martha now it's taken quite a
long time to get to this point it was an
incident that shocked the world and and
now a lot of reaction to this decision
today
yeah there certainly is it's taken more
than a year to get here it's been an
extensive investigation by the
authorities in New Mexico a report last
year was released uh hundreds of pages
long uh massive amounts of video footage
and interviews for them to Wade through
but they have finally announced these
charges to individuals facing two counts
of involuntary manslaughter Hollywood
veteran Alec Baldwin the actor who was
holding the gun when that fatal bullet
was discharged and also Hannah Gutierrez
read the omara who was in charge of
weapons on that set now in New Mexico
law involuntary manslaughter charges
mean that they didn't have the intent to
kill but it happened because of more
than mere negligence because they didn't
exercise due caution and I spoke to many
people who were on the set of the film
rust who had raised prior to the
shooting concerns about safety on set
one individual said they they never felt
as safe as unsafe as they did when they
were on that set he said there was a
total disregard for the welfare and
safety of cast and crew and clearly the
district attorney in Santa Fe in New
Mexico agrees they say that they've got
more than enough to get through a
preliminary hearing charge they think
they do have probable cause to continue
with these charges
um now Alec Baldwin was given prior
notice
um that he would be charged in this case
with involuntary manslaughter but just
in last few moments his lawyer has
released a statement they say this
decision distorts Helena Hutchins tragic
death and represents a terrible
miscarriage of Justice Mr Baldwin had no
reason to believe there was a live
bullet in the gun or anywhere on the
movie Set he relied on the professionals
with whom he worked who assured him that
the gun did not have live rounds we will
fight these charges and we will win so a
confident note from Alec Baldwin's
lawyer there just as a reminder of what
happened in October 2021 there was
rehearsals going on so this wasn't a
filming of the actual uh scene this was
a rehearsal inside a church set in New
Mexico you can see it there and Helena
Hutchins was filming as Alec Baldwin
pulled this prop gun out of a holster
now Alec Baldwin admits that he pulled
back the Hammer of the gun so that's the
back part of the gun but he's always
denied pulling the trigger and in fact
in interviews he's pointedly said that
he doesn't feel guilt over Helena
hutchin's death although he has
expressed his condolences to her husband
and son he has always denied pulling the
trigger what you see there this video
has been released by the Santa Fe County
Sheriff's Office and this is the
immediate aftermath
um of that incident as police try to
investigate what happened to 42 year old
Helena Hutchins a rising star in the
cinematography world and certainly
people I've been speaking to say that
they've been fighting for this criminal
accountability for Helena Hutchins death
they say they've had lawsuits have been
filed countersuits have been filed as
this game of blame and counter blame has
played out but this is the first step
towards any criminal Reckoning and the
family of Helena Hutchins have welcomed
this move they released a statement in
the wake of these charges being
announced they said we want to thank the
Santa Fe sheriff and the district
attorney for concluding their thorough
investigation and determining that
charges for involuntary manslaughter are
warranted for the killing of Helena
Hutchins with conscious disregard for
human life our independent investigation
also supports charges are warranted it's
a comfort to the family that in New
Mexico no one is above the law we
support the charges we'll fully
cooperate with this prosecution and
fervently hope the justice system works
to protect the public and hold
accountable those who break the law
in addition to these statements that
we've had from the Santa Fe District
Attorney's office and from Helena
Hutchins family Andrea Reeb who's a
special prosecutor in this case made the
note that if any one of these three
people so Alec Baldwin the armor of
Hannah Gutierrez read and also David
Halls the assistant director who's made
a plea deal in connection with this case
she said if any one of those three had
done their job Helena Hutchins would be
alive today it's that simple she also
noted that the evidence they've
collected shows a pattern of criminal
disregard for safety on the film set and
that is in accordance with what we heard
in the wake of this shooting from crew
members and in fact seven crew members
just the day before Helena Hutchins was
shot dead walked offset in protest over
what they viewed as a willful disregard
for the safety of cast and crew on set
so they're were warnings given in
advance of this and in fact that's
something that the district attorney has
drawn upon
um when she announced the charges
against Alec bald when she said he was
not only an actor on this set he was
also one of the producers and he was a
veteran actor she said and they say that
in in line with this investigation
they've spoken to many A-list actors who
have said that they regularly check the
guns on set even if they're prop guns
they check to see if they've got live
bullets in or they asked someone else to
do so that so the Santa Fe District
Attorney's Office clearly believe they
have enough evidence to proceed with
these charges okay Martha Kellner for
now thanks very much